Mitchell?
Langham?
Hey, Cam, it's Langham and Tim.
Hi. Hey.
What are you boys doing here?
Bachelor party weekend.
We're getting married in June.
What? Oh, we really wanted to invite
you, but Tim's family is huge.
Relax. We're getting married in May,
and you're not coming, so.
Oh, look at us. Moving on.
It's almost like you never dumped me in
an email the morning after I told you
that I loved you.
Well, in my defense e-mail, it was new
back then, and it was still blurry line
as to what was appropriate.
And, well, we have a pretty packed
weekend. Oh, we do.
But if you guys have some time, here's
our itinerary. Okay.
Come play. Yo.
Yeah. Fun, you guys.
Congratulations. Thank you.
Oh, my gosh. An actual gay agenda.
Oh, come on.
It looks like we're not going to see
much of you two this trip.
No, no, no. We are not participating in
any of this.
They're very judgy about bachelor
parties. I offered to throw them one,
and I got a whole lecture.
We're 40. We have a child.
We've been together for ten years.
That's the one. It's just not who we
are anymore. Listen to this.
Bananas and cabanas pool party.
Yeah. Most creative Speedo wins tickets
to the kilty pleasures.
No, please. What is the kilty pleasures?
This.
We will be maintaining our dignity and
the spa. Thank you.
I mean, come on.
Have you ever seen a Scottish person
this tan? I'm embarrassed even looking
at it. Then.
Stop.
I love cucumber water.
I know. If I were president.
I know. I know. Cucumbers in the
reservoirs.
Giant cucumbers.
Mr. Pritchett? Yes?
Hi. All right. I'll see you in 90
minutes. Enjoy. Thank you.
Mr. Tucker. Mr.
Tucker.
We had a few no shows for the Britney
concert.
So. One, please.
What about Mitchell?
It's Vegas. He doesn't need to know what
I'm doing. I don't need to know what
he's doing. So if you see him, maybe
don't mention what I'm doing.
Oh, understood.
So do you have anything on the aisle?
Hey, big spender. What are you doing?
Gambling.
I'm a gambler now.
Look at you letting loose.
Yeah, I guess I figure whatever mischief
one might get into in Vegas kind of
remains here within the limits of this
city. You know.
That's a cool way to think.
About it. You know, I'm really glad that
you came over here.
Oh, really? Why is that?
Well, I always hated the way that things
ended between us.
You know, maybe now we can go out on a
better note. That's nice.
Yeah. Oh, my God.
Six, two, three, three.
That's. That's my room number, Huh?
Hit me.
Seven! That's 21, huh?
Yes. Yes.
Well, check you out.
I guess tonight's my night to get lucky.
I would say thank you.
Maybe I will run into you again.
Oh.
120. 140 Higgins for nothing.
Nothing. I want to do something crazy.
Okay? I'm going to order a bath.
Sir, it sounds to me like you've gone
mad.
Okay, This is what I want. I want
something romantic, but also a little
dangerous.
Romantic. Dangerous.
Might I suggest, sir, the techno bath.
Your heart will throb with the bass
while your eyes take in an off the
scale laser light show from that most
intimate of VIP arenas.
Your own tub.
Okay, I want that. That's what I want.
Me thinks the little Red Riding Hood may
be a big bad wolf. I'll be back shortly
with supplies.
Oh, good. I've been looking for you.
Well, you should have been looking for
somebody who was looking for you,
because that's what I was doing.
Come on. I have a surprise for you.
Oh, yeah.
I've been thinking. We need to stop
being so uptight. We are in Vegas.
Let's have a little fun.
Well, I'll have to wrap my head around
that, but.
Okay. I have just the way to kick it
off. Something we could do together.
It's a little extreme, but I think it
might be just what we need.
Go on.
Are you crazy?
Oh, come on, Cam. We deserve this.
All right, you get started, and then
I'll jump in when it starts to heat up.
Mitchell.
Come on. Then I will throw you into a
tiger. Rub a dub dub.
You gotta know.
Langham.
Both of.
You. Well, okay.
No, no, no, not okay.
What are you doing here? You gave me
your room key.
What?
Don't act so shocked.
You told me the bachelor party.
You two lead separate lives.
You went.
To the bachelor.
Party? Yes. And I was starting to feel
bad about sneaking around.
But I guess I shouldn't have.
Now that I see what you're up to, I'm
not up to anything.
I left my key by mistake.
We're all obviously tense.
Let's take a deep breath.
Get in the tub.
It's not happening.
You want to tell me how you accidentally
gave someone your key?
You want to tell me why you spent all
day sipping tequila out of some guy's
navel? You saw that?
I guessed.
Hi, guys. What's going.
On? Hey, Claire, Can you please just
come back? We're in the middle of an
argument.
Oh, I bet I know why.
Are you guys.
Getting in the bath?
Oh, I'm way off.
Langham. It's Tim.
He can't know I'm here.
He has insane trust issues.
Insane. Langham, are you in there?
Go out this door. In here.